avec christian chou via le père de
cédric joue via cris s'en souvient
bonsoir merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors on l'a vu
trois policiers sont mis en examen pour
homicide involontaire une quatrième
fonctionnaires est placé sous le statut
de témoin assisté
malgré les soupçons très graves qui
pèsent sur eux le ministère de
l'intérieur estime que les suspendre de
leurs fonctions
elle n'est pas justifiée quelle est
votre réaction c'est toujours le le fait
que monsieur darmanin est en train de
délivrer des permis de tuer je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on peut tu quand on est
de la police on peut tuer librement on a
peur on a pas de recours
darmanin couvre tout l'allemand le
préfet de police de paris couvre tous à
tous couverts au début de la faire et
aujourd'hui on continue avec le couvert
de notre président de la république
puisqu'il espère tout ça depuis plus de
18 mois et je pense qu'aujourd'hui on
est dans un scandale de liberté de
liberté de tous c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes dans la rue on
vous contrôle on vous tue qu'est ce qui
s'est passé pour ses briques confie
cédric on va contrôler on l'a tué soit
aucun motif le 21 juillet 2021
l'igpn qu'est la police des polices
relève des contradictions dans le récit
des policiers puis ils sont mis en
examen pour homicide involontaire
le ministère de l'intérieur le ministre
de l'intérieur pardon arman en reste
fidèle aux policiers vraisemblablement à
moins d'un an des présidentielles
pourquoi selon vous parce que il a une
position ferme et définitive c'est qui
veut couvrir tous ses policiers
les bons comme les mauvais surtout les
mauvais qui sont là en fin de compte
avec un permis de tuer je le répète je
dis la position d'art mince et il
lâchait il lâche ces gens pour que s'il
ya débat
c'est pas des bavures ans et s'il ya une
intention de tuer il ya des moments il
ya une intention de tuer alors que ça
soit un contrôle de police banal où que
ce soit
comment une arrestation violente parce
qu'il ya des violences lui il fait il
fait pas de détail la ferraille est
claire je suis désolé on voit trois
policiers fracasser des fonds c'est un
gars là on les a mis en prison pendant
quinze jours on les aperçoit retire
prendre pour que les enfants aient
sauvés alors papa pour les fêtes de noël
c'est un scandale c'est un scandale
jc/dc une bavure
il faut que j'essaie mais les caméras
ont filmé pareil l'assassinât de mon
fils il a été filmé dans les mêmes
conditions
y aller les caméras extérieures commande
publique est allé les témoins les vidéos
il ya des témoignages comme quoi que on
a entendu le son de sa voix
alors quand monsieur darmana se permet
de dire quand monsieur d'arman se permet
de dire lui quand j'entends les
violences policières
j'étouffe si ça c'est pas une si vous
voulez pas prendre ça comme un coup de
poignard pour la famille shaw bien on a
tous ressenti comme un coup de poignard
c'était peser calculer son mot il était
pesé calculer est-ce que je pense que
monsieur darmanin n'est pas n'est pas
inquiet je pense que c'est une personne
intelligente et ce qui fait ce qu'il dit
il le pèze christian julia justement
pour vous utilisez des mots très forts
vous parlez de permis de tuer la police
nationale à officialiser le remplacement
est de la technique de clé
d'étranglement par trois nouvelles
pratiques et c'est cette technique
d'interpellations qui est mise en cause
dans le décès de votre fils est ce que
c'est une bonne chose selon vous est ce
que ça peut arranger les uns les futurs
interpellation lapied d'étranglement
c'est une bonne chose pour arrêter le
pacage mentale parce que quand vous avez
200 kg 250 kilos sur le dos vous pouvais
plus respirer ce que je voulais vous
dire aussi c'est que cédric n'est pas
mort d'un malaise cardiaque
il est mort étouffé on l'a étouffé on a
tué il n'est pas mort d'un malaise des
rémois 7l j'étouffe et ses derniers mots
ça a été j'ai tout cette fois avant
qu'on se réveille et alors le qi commis
c'est que la seule personne qui est
témoin assisté il ya un an j'ai rien vu
mais alors avec témoin cité quoi est
elle partie elle est comme les autres la
valeur à jour elle est comme les autres
comics elle perez l'assassin moi je pèse
mais bon moi je sais qui je m'adresse
tous les deux sites nous à 60
christian je viens d'autres d'autres
sombres affaires sont malheureusement
similaire à celle de votre fils et à la
adama traoré l'agression michel est
clair vous en avait parlé il y en a
plusieurs autres
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui qu'est ce qui
permettrait à votre votre famille de
tenir aujourd'hui même si la blessure
est l'état vie qu'est ce qui vous donne
la force de tenir vous et votre famille
c'est la justice aujourd'hui la justice
fait un travail énorme
nous on en a les comptes rendus par les
avocats tout ça ils font un travail
énorme
ils veulent la vérité la justice veut la
vérité elle fait tout pour la retrouver
elle va la trouver
je pense qu'elle va la retrouver
maintenant le jugement on attend ça avec
impatience à sera-t-il dans deux ans
dans trois ans on sait pas mais quand il
aura jugement nathan sac un passant mais
aujourd'hui je peux dire une chose c'est
que dans tous les to les policiers ne
sont pas des michael perez faut pas
rêver on n'a jamais pensé ça me dit ça
met dedans quand on a des fruits pourris
faut les mettre au rancart tout de suite
et je pèse mes mots parce que c'est des
gens ils sont cédés à sas en puissance
la preuve il avait déjà une affaire
similaire avant et la deuxième le beau
fils il a il n'a pas tenu le choc et il
en est mort fracture du larynx
étouffement et 200 kg de guerre sur le
paletot il pouvait pas s'en sortir c'est
impossible qui s'en sort
c'était impossible vous pouvez demander
à tous les grands sportifs de judo de
karaté ou n'importe quoi ils voulaient
rendre à situation n'était c'est
impossible donc il l'a fait sciemment il
a continué sciemment à faire ce qu'ils
voulaient faire parce qu'il savait qu'il
avait un couvert il est barman et il est
bon en fait au départ d'arrêter pendant
le show kaka qui a bien répondu à
présent c'est caceres castanheira dit
j'enlèverai l'acte étranglement il l'a
enlevée ont ils il a eu tous les
syndicats dans son bureau
ça fait bouger on a remis la clé
d'étranglement tout de suite ça a duré
48 heures où je crois trois jours on a
remis la clé prononce que tous les
syndicats se sont manifestés on nous
enlève nos outils de travail
rendez compte on nous enlève nos outils
de travail il ya mort d'homme on parle
d' outil de travail quand il ya mort
d'homme d'accord et d'armes a revu si
vous si vous pouviez a rapidement
adressé un mot à un gérald darmanin pour
finir cette interview c'est darmanin
faites votre travail
quand vous avez des fruits pourris dans
votre saladier ont levé mettez les à
pied c'est tout ce qu'on vous demande
vous demande pas grand chose et on y re
jugement paisiblement
vous comprenez monsieur norman
ce que je peux vous dire c'est déjà pas
mal je vous remercie je vous remercie
infiniment pour pour cette interview et
bon courage à vous dans cette épreuve
difficile avec votre famille merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions sur arte
france